okay yes I think we'll start a time but
before that let's make a bit a little
bit of a survey how many of you guys
ever used bird
the model how many of you guys
pre-trained bird
okay two of us uh
I I need to apologize at the sound I'm
native speaker Russian and I missed lots
of English classes so don't judge me
hard for that
um
I think the presentation today will be
not that technical as I wanted to be but
okay I'll start I'll uh
explain you what is the semantic search
and how to build that
okay we have one minute less because
it's a bit an RM and some you guys come
during the presentation so we'll wait
one more minutes
so yeah
foreign
the full name is Vladimir so you can
call it me as a wish I'm research
engineer
a deep learning research engineer and
Unum is a startup where we first of all
build databases so one of the modern
databases retro database the database
where you can find the similar object by
their Vector representation so that's
why my talk for today is about the
semantic search there's lots of actually
buzzwords here on the top so multimodal
multilingual so we will discuss today
how to make your your model multilingual
and maybe how to make your semantic
search engine multi-model
uh so we will see what is designed uh
where is the encoding part of your
queries and your database where you can
try to search something uh we'll discuss
the indexes
um yeah
lingual models as well and we'll speak
about the future uh we'll speak about
the a little bit of production so how to
build the efficient semantic search
okay
so why we even need this magic search
why we need the more intelligent search
than the exact uh or lexical search okay
a picture of the query you want to find
the fastest animal and you are trying to
find the images and actually the both
sensor are sometimes can happen uh the
fast snail snail is animal
obviously but and you can get it as a
response but that's not the way you want
it so you wanted to find the horse uh so
yeah let's try to build this search a
bit more tangent
then the lexical exact search so the
difference is that for this semantics
charge you work not with the source form
of data it works with their
representation representations or
embeddings so you want to try to put
your query and all your database in some
Universal Vector space such that your
query and the potential answer or
response are close in the space
uh so yeah double cache the applications
of it it's uh wide the first of all the
web search so Google being I don't know
lots of others uh are already using
semantic search so you actually buy the
textual query can find the image you can
find the YouTube video the piece of the
audio and the the htmls so there is lots
of other implementations one that is the
semantic search engines itself
you can use the semantic search for
recommender systems because the problem
is very similar uh it's also used for
question answering systems not only
actually open domain but where others a
matching problem the problem where you
try to find the similar object in the
internet so for instance you in the
Amazon you find good and you want to
find the similar in the eBay and so the
semantic search
also have helpful for that and the
conversational response selection that
is for my previous background uh
actually in assistant voice assistance
structural assistance you can use uh not
only generative models but the
conversational translations that when
when you can have lots of potential
responses for the query and you're
trying to find the most similar for that
so you have the pre-built uh database
based with answers
okay uh so what is the design we can
we can think of the semantic search with
the two main parts first of all you
should encode your data your database
whatever modality it has so you need to
encode your database put it somewhere
and we will say build in this but we
will explain what is the index a bit
later and the second part is the search
itself when you have a query you already
have pre-built vectors for your database
you need to encode your query as well
after that you need to find the similar
the the I don't know K nearest neighbor
for instance for your in your database
so uh yeah Top gay candidates and after
that you will have the result for your
query
so yeah the part of encoding so actually
lots of you might know that we cannot
only text images but we can uncut
everything and what we are trying to
achieve is that we want to encode
everything in one universal Vector space
so for instance by querying the text you
are trying to find the image or maybe a
piece of the audio or maybe called
or 3D objects
so yeah today we will talk a lot about
the textual queries because it's you can
find you you can face it more often uh
so for the textual queries and textual
data uh mostly used sentence
Transformers so the neural Nets when
you're trying to encode uh to have the
embedding not only for the words but for
whole sentences so for that you just can
put the pulling layer that will average
the warden weddings after the encoding
by the words
so yeah here the link for the sentence
Transformers is somebody not familiar
with that
okay but there is uh various object
training objectives for the sentence
sentence Transformers or encoders so
uh
I have actually the question for you
guys uh can you say what is what is the
problem with two right objectives these
two right architectures for the search
whites can be complicated
thank you
okay
yeah yeah the right answer uh if you
have the query uh for the let's say
cross encoder you need for every single
Vector in your database you need to use
your neural net so it's complex
computationally complex so you can't use
it for retrieval actually so mostly for
retrieval problem B encoder is used and
not the whole architecture but the only
one part of that as an encoder as a
vector representation for the text
uh so yeah why we need the two uh
residuals actually uh with the search
problem we sometimes uh trying to have
two parts of the search process the
first of all is the retrieval part so
where where we we can find the top K
candidates so after that let's say k is
10 we can use uh the different
architectures so like cross encoders so
pulling coders because it's
computational not that costly
uh
so okay
but we're not using the Nave K and N
implementation like we're not trying to
find actual K nearest neighbors
sometimes for that we use instances you
can think of it like that is the data
structures when you can find something
more quickly than the Nave
implementations like Nave k n so uh the
lsh kitty trees and the original double
graphs as all that stretches that where
you can find not exact cannons but
approximate K and ends faster than in
the naive approach
so yeah there's lots of implementation
of such algorithms so such instances
you can find all of them in a repository
called n and Benchmark there is The
Benchmark where a developers was was
able to use a CPU only and they got a as
far as a no contains like 1 million
vectors with different dimensions and
and there's lots of benchmarks such that
where you have the queries per second
and the actual measures of the quality
the recall
so yeah you can find the best suitable
algorithm for yourself for your exact
problem and this is actually built very
easy to use you can just leave few call
a few lines of sales script and that
will work well this everything's
dockerized and very suitable to use Okay
so
uh so yeah how to make your model
multilingual and why you could why we
are curious about that so the Internet
contact by languages uh
actually looks like that so there's lots
of English contact in the internet but
not that a lot of users who use actually
who who's speaking in a language is
English so probably in sometimes in I
don't know in the nearest Future the
content will be more multilingual that's
why we all think about how to make our
uh applications multilingual so the
search have to be also multilingual
so yeah how we can do that
uh there is lots of approaches actually
one of which if you have data for the
pre-trained in multilingual mode you can
do that but in most cases you don't have
such because the distribution between
languages for pre-trained uh sometimes
like I don't know 80 English and a 20
else or something with that so yeah we
can use some tricks one of which is you
can pre-train in higher resource
languages few of them I I think though
Deutsche Spanish English
uh Mandarin maybe yeah and after that
you will find some walrus languages like
minion uh that's one of the approach the
second one is knowledge installation
it's the approach when you're trying to
make your student model multilingual if
you teach her model already multilingual
so you can take the big multilingual uh
pre-trained teacher model and try to do
to uh
to to make a distillation for the
student model that will will make it
multilingual as well and maybe the
student model will be I don't know less
per part
a bad word yeah my English ah so okay uh
a few words about multimodal
representations so yeah as as I already
mentioned we want to have for example
textual query and image as a result or
textual query and video as a result or
maybe mesh
or piece of the code so how can we do
that what is the universal Vector
there's a presentation
uh yeah one of the most uh well-known
approach is clip built by open AI That's
the model which is actually
has the
structure as the
Bean coder so that's dual encoder model
so you have the encoder here and here
uh so after you uh have the embeddings
of the
um
prepare prepared data of images and
texts you'll have their embeddings and
you already know that's the this picture
is about is uh
similar with this text and so as the
ground crucial have the identity Matrix
and
in the training process you have the
measures in uh where in the cell you'll
have the similarity score for the
embeddings for instance cosine
similarity or maybe that product or
something like that
uh yeah and the right picture is about
the implementation itself and actually
you can see that the clip model is the
retrieval model itself but for the
single query you will have to encode
every single uh potential responses that
you have to so you every uh their
database but you don't need to do that
because you have indexes battery indexes
uh yeah the clip architecture the
encoder part of for the text is the
encoder part of the Transformer so it's
bird-like model but not
uh obligatory bird you can use whatever
LM you wanted so yeah it's just
transform the best encoder part and you
also can make the knowledge distillation
to make it multilingual so already you
have the United Universal Vector space
for multilingual text and images so you
can find through it
to make a search so for clip image
encoders in the original paper the
reason that was used and the v80 so the
vision Transformers uh and the training
objective is the contrastive loss the
the loss that was mentioned here so the
ground truth is identity Matrix once
again and and the similarity scores in
for the as the predictions
ah okay
yes yeah that what we want to achieve so
we want to have textile query
and the potential image and in our
Universal Vector space we want to have
it similar
uh yeah between each other in terms of
again similarity measure whatever you
will pick Dutch product sounds similar
to anything else
so yeah there's some tips and tricks
that uh I already
understand during the working with Clips
uh the first of all is uh clip is very
sensitive model so uh
try to keep your normalization layers uh
Frozen during fine tune and actually
sometimes during the late approach in
the pre-training uh yeah always try to
to start with the learning AIDs that low
and maybe keep it for the whole
pre-training process
uh yeah the clip is very sensitive for
the data so try to filter that as much
as you can and properly Shuffle
the original repository for the clip is
not that good there is no training
scripts no fine tuning strips nothing
actually but only the architecture so if
you want to train or fine tune the clip
try to use open clip implementation by
some guys from Google as far as I
remember and stand for
yeah and for
uh fine-tuning or this knowledge
distillation of your textual model yeah
use sentence performance that was
already mentioned before and the yes
clip
training pre-training clip and also fire
tuning clip uh requires lots of GPU
power so be ready
okay uh what if we want to add more
modalities so actually there is a lot of
research about the approach for Trend
multi-model models for lots of
modalities like text audio video I don't
know images
that's one of them this said the
architecture from the paper called audio
clip the ID is actually the same so you
are trying to
and called every piece of data you have
and you already have the you already
know that the picture uh the textual uh
description and the piece of the audio
are the same or similar and where we can
find that we can find it from video yeah
we can try to separate video by the
audio or the picture the tag sometimes
we have a textual description of the
segments of video and so on but that's
always challenging so
so yeah there is some papers so once
called audio clip for video video clips
the defenses of the ml Engineers I have
format is called Crosspoint uh but yeah
there's also the problem the source of
the data to find the proper data set to
self-supervised learning so you want to
scrap internet
uh in most cases you don't want to build
it yourself or maybe human labeling it's
not it's not that you cannot take the
volume of the data set that you want to
so you need to find something okay for
audio text and video and text you can
use videos but not very not lots of
videos and for example on YouTube are
properly labeled
or imagine you want to find the data set
where's the three various meshes are
actually descripted it's actually very
complicated
okay that is the example what we are
trying to achieve so as you can see here
is the check show query
and actually lots of images is the
results uh like smaller on Cat and this
query could be like potentially in every
other language which is the script which
is used to description for every image
we have
uh but not only that not only the
textual query is interesting uh in the
fashion industry right now every single
application uh that are trying to make
your to make you to to give you a link
for some I don't know Amazon Goods on
something like that uh with this search
are using the same technology actually
so you can put the image as a query and
find the similar images because
sometimes it's hard to describe the
goods I don't know the closest uh
sneakers how to describe it it's
complicated so you can just take a
picture and find similar
okay uh moving to production yeah in the
previous the pi data Meetup I was the
speaker as well and we actually uh and I
actually spoke a lot about the speeding
up the language models
so that is the number and you can take
not only the bird or the steel bird you
can try other uh
models from Central Transformers and you
can try to speed it up how you can do
that it's like a little bit a long talk
and you can see my presentation
following the link but to be short it's
always about the quantization so you can
use the different
runtimes for that like Onyx on time or
tensor runtime uh so and and other
libraries to accelerate to in GPU on CPU
your language models and that is crucial
for semantic search because you need the
high bandwidth uh
okay as I already mentioned uh lots of
uh database companies or startups right
now are trying to make their own Vector
database so the semantic search engine
and uh actually we are trying to build
uh
areas error of the database so the key
Value Store the document database the
graph database and Vector database
itself also and lots of modern database
already have the semantic search as the
component so when you're query in
through the documents actually sometimes
the the documents in the database itself
has the index inside already
uh so yeah
I think that's
pretty much it for today
so
please welcome your questions are
appreciated
thanks a lot for your attention
[Applause]
hi hi uh okay so my question is is
um
this is my understanding correct that
when you want to do a query against the
graph database or document database or
any of those presentations or
information you create similar kind of
indices and then you might query against
them
uh so you are trying to encode every
single piece of data that you have in
the Universal database so so a universal
Vector representation so all the vectors
you have no matter what is the modality
of the source data will be held on the
same let's say multi-dimensional space
yeah multi-dimensional space so you can
build index uh like through it to the
whole this data so
I I don't think the for every single
models you have the separate Index this
will be the mission for everything and
you use something like arteries and so
on for indices
uh we used or you you guys use we
actually mostly we use the files
implementation hnsw with some
quantization so yeah uh lots of indices
implementation of the indices right now
not work with the bare vectors that you
have after the representation learning
it's some it's mostly quantize the
vector or maybe trying to lower the
dimension of the vectors and the
so-called pre-processing and uh you we
use the Asians double with some
pre-processing you see and lots of them
actually uh already pre-built in face so
face is a great repository guys uh there
is also not only the CPU version to the
indices but also the GPU version and in
the repository big inm Benchmark you can
find lots of implementations for GPU
versions and actually I think one of
them only uh open sourced it's the face
yeah in Phase deep distribution yeah I
mean we also use face yeah
uh yeah and one more follow-up question
if you don't mind yeah
um
do you have any idea or desire to add a
reasoning on top of your graphs
so I mean when you do some kind of
semantic search it's one story because
you like you'll find objects that mostly
correspond to the queries that you got
in the beginning but if you represent
data as a graph view one of one of the
benefits of the graph is you can add
Anthology on top of it and then you can
do reasoning so what do you have any
desire to build something like that into
your system
we have desire but we didn't uh like got
there that's already built a solution
for that so we like and we're looking
for the research about that okay yeah
thank you so much thanks a lot
I think for a great presentation uh did
you use uh open source data sets to
train systems yeah okay uh we actually
have the chunk of the uh common crawl so
we try to filter it by ourselves and try
to train it on it but actually mostly
right now for pre-trained multilingual
clip that I'm doing right now actually
we use the open source data set called
lion
uh there is two versions of it one of
the four million pairs for English only
and in the last releases like two months
ago three months ago they released the
data set with 5 billion pairs which half
of it is multilingual so right now we
I already be close to download
and I already tried to pre-train on on
chunk of it in
let's say five terabytes no no three
terabytes chunk of it and it's pretty
straight in the multilingual clip and
it's close to good enough actually uh in
sentence Transformers you can find
multilingual clip as well but it's not
pre-trained it's no it's it's it has the
knowledge distillation and the metrics
are closed but in my feeling that more
data you have the more data you show to
the clip the better the results
uh so yeah it's about uh buyer's image
and sentences yes what about audios uh
for that there is not lots of uh open
source data sets and we actually right
now we didn't add in the like production
version or algorithm the third modality
and we also it's more like research and
the mattresses is not that good and we
think actually maybe the how
architecture is not appropriate for
three and more modalities so that for
audio and text you can use podcasts
actually that's uh audio set is uh can
contain two million uh audios with uh
videos with capture with textual
captures yeah yeah no these images but
you can train uh these players images
and in the audio text separately you can
train yeah
there is some data sets but two million
pairs it's uh my point of view is not
enough because for text and uh images uh
for Trend the like clip they got 4
million of 400 million pairs in a
regional paper
as far as I remember and now enough
there is open source data that has
two and a half billion pairs
you can for example extract from YouTube
uh Place audios and Frames yes yes but
you need to filter this data properly
because that's uh
uh the detectional description for
instance uh mostly incorrect In My in
description just only images and audio
yeah okay
audio
text is
Virginia
okay uh that's actually not uh work like
that I think so I didn't found the the
papers that you can train uh text image
and image audio separately and after
that you will have the whole I don't
know good representation for the uh text
and audio
so I think it should be I I I'm sure
they should be trained like in the same
at the same time so you need to label
data for all the modalities you want to
see in your Universal virtual space
maybe maybe I'm incorrect but show me
the paper
okay the property of transitivity
yeah I understand but I I I think you'll
you will you will try
um you will train different spaces for
different pairs you see and after that
you need to match it
so maybe it will work if you will add
the some dense layers
uh in the head of your encoders and
train it to somehow match your vector
spaces no if but in the better in the
bear implementation I don't think is
fixed for example okay fix it during
players audio
okay
but I don't see the connection I cannot
follow that so
no if more model parameters are fixed
and not not changed I think
yeah yeah but but but but but but
Vector spaces would be different
if you if you train it to the in the
pairs of modalities it will be different
and you need to somehow match that
yeah or I I think so I think so okay
ah yeah yeah the nose this version okay
uh yeah I'll try to elaborate
um
actually the distillation somehow uh
some most of the time used to make your
model a bit less weighty so you are
trying to use as a student model the
model with less parameters
but that's not the only case sometimes
distillation
Works to distribute your knowledge from
the teacher model to the student model
but it's I don't know the volume of the
models are the same so you can actually
buy the distillation transfer the
knowledge
imagine the teacher models is sentence
based model and the student model is
word based model and by this
distillation you will make the sentence
model sentence based as well so it will
encode embed the the sentences better so
the same idea is for the languages
uh so you can try
to encode
but so so you can try to transfer the
multilingual uh MultiLing I don't know
how to say it in English Okay the
multilingual skill from the teacher
model to the student model by the
distillation so you'll have the mutual
loss for the both models and by that
your teacher model will learn the
multilinguality as well
foreign
okay I see uh actually in the in in cold
uh in the architecture you add the
pulling layers sometimes and the dense
layer and the top of the models to to to
to the student model to teach something
but you don't keep your model Frozen so
the parameters are not from
so yeah
any more questions yeah
so the clip architecture that you
described it only allows as far as I
understand two or three modalities right
do we have any architectures that scale
well with more modalities so uh I'll
I'll say that there is lots of research
about that the model is called uh
let me remind that uh
okay there is the models the the which
are trying to achieve the multi more
multimodal training for lots of
modalities for lots of tasks uh and
there is some successes but I personally
didn't see the good implementation of it
so maybe in some private data sets in
big big companies it works but in open
source I thought the only one repository
related with or maybe two repositories
is related to three modalities and lots
of photo modalities like text and images
there's lots of uh
good implementations but for three and
more I I I'm not sure but we are working
on it
thank you it's called fundamental models
you can try to find it in Purpose with
code there is lots of research
okay
here's the guy yeah thanks
yeah thanks a lot for the talk I
apologize for a stupid question because
it is caused by my lack of experience in
the field so as you said when you encode
the data from different modalities into
single Vector space okay you use
different
encoders specialized encoders and so I
imagine if you want to achieve like
consistency between the different
modalities the encoders have to have
some consistency right
is there like
a well-established way on achieving that
aside from picking the correct data or
the consistency what is the consistency
what do you mean
I guess uh
the encoders for example the birth
encoder on the textual side the resident
on the images side
you can take them pre-trained right but
yeah some fine tuning has to be done or
okay okay okay yeah
I need to yeah I need to explain
something that okay you can take the
pre-trained models as the initialization
of the clip but clip itself also had the
pre-training so actually you can think
about it as a fine tuning but you you'll
have lots of data lots of epochs and
lots of uh time to train gpus and so on
so forth so that is actually the
pre-train itself uh the contrastive
losses lost football for yeah it's you
can call it fine tune but actually it's
the pre-training so there is lots of
data lots of Step of learning uh uh this
scheduling for learning rate
and so on so forth so yeah to achieve
this consistency
as far as I understood understand what
you mean uh yeah you make the pre-train
for the clip itself
whenever you're initialize that
initialize the clip from
do for a presentation uh I wanted to ask
you is there any way to
um so recently I was reading that like
meta
AI published that they have this NLB
model no language Left Behind uh it's a
text
I'm texting and they open source their
their text encodings and they say it
works on 200 languages
so even low research languages are
included uh I want to test is there any
way to use just this text models to make
it a multi-modal somehow I don't know
for example using as a teacher model to
have this method yeah that's possible
but the problem I think that this model
is too weighty that doesn't fit the uh I
don't know any GPU cluster that is
existing around in Armenia for instance
so as far as I remember the meta models
were really huge the weather model so
I'm personally used like a little bit
less apparately models like multilingual
bird or maybe T5 uh with a base version
of the models but yeah you can you can
you for sure can use that because it's
easy to it's easy to calculate the msci
uh or maybe some other contrast it was
okay thank you so you can take whatever
you want
okay since there's no other questions uh
thank you all for the attention
[Applause]